he loved Fitness ever since his dad
brought home a gym in the 6th grade he's
been an actor spokesperson and model for
various commercials brands and causes
he's one of the most recognized and
motivating people in the fitness
industry
he's Greg Plitt and here are his top 10
rules for success how you see it
whatever the truth is your perception on
how you see that truth outweighs at 10
to one so it's a motivation and why
you're doing it you know it's in a
journey of getting in shape it's a long
long run right the person who's standing
at the end with their hand raised isn't
the person with all the genetics it
isn't the person of the most potential
it's the person that has the greatest
perseverance it's always willing to get
out the difference between a champion
and a loser is that the you know they
both fail as the loser allows the
failure to stand for life with a
champion even though it gets knocked on
his ass Ron's details poured through to
stand back up reface that endeavor until
it becomes his favor until he wins
that's the difference champions get back
up and do it again and a difference
between someone and successful here or
some of the spectator here is that a
person is successful you know they
believe in themselves so much and their
belief overrides any crowds disbelief it
have to be a student of the game you
know what nutrition is what
supplementation is why you're trained
you can't be a blind squirrel trying to
find the nut every day meaning you have
to know what you're doing and or if your
body to change it starts at the top of
the greatest muscle why you're doing
what you're doing if you're not stood in
the game then you don't understand
the ins and outs of each daily operation
success is nothing to do with potential
it's all about the perseverance of
somebody that will override any endeavor
if you throw against the wall eventually
something will stick
you guys that are had this potential
don't have this potential you know
that's guys what continues to last
forever is a perseverance always show up
that's what champions do every single
champion the same as every ordinary
person knowing differentials that they
show up to the event every single day
they see failure as a learning curve
they welcome failure you learn more from
failure than you ever will from success
so showing up and get knocked on your
ass
finally test one for to stand back up
Andrea they said endeavour it's going to
be the overriding factor that makes a
difference how do you know when you're
doing those things the small things in
life add up to those big monumental
things why send small things it's a
character building block that your name
means something you hold value to your
name if you drop trash from the ground
you pick it up that's a responsibility
you hold value to yourself when you
shake someone's hand you look them in
the eye giving firm a handshake
if you're here for a purpose everything
you do you do to the best of your
ability
doesn't know what you're doing is it
that that you're doing it so therefore
it means something to you that's gonna
build a legacy because you know the
title out there doesn't mean you win the
title fine that title will not get you
another title what you're trying to
build its legacy you know footprint
behind you there are left motivation for
someone else to follow legacy is built
daily through the character the
willpower the code of conduct within
some life and that's the perseverance
showing up every single day that will
always achieve the goal it doesn't
matter what you're born with it doesn't
matter potential how much you know
silver spoon of money you have all that
can be attained if you show up and
you're willing to to risk failure for
success I went through the life in the
military in sports and I always used the
gym for some means it was never about
fitness modeling
I said passionate for working out every
time I hit struggles or all stressed out
I was going to the gym to find solidity
there the work through any kind of
stresses so naturally I got in shape but
it wasn't for a fitness model in those
four military and sports and then later
on down the road an agent's agency soul
mates at age 2 take some pictures and
I'll try it and as how this was born but
it wasn't the starting I didn't start
out set up with us it just ended up
coming through passion and the lovely
gym I could teach you whatever you know
but when you go out there you try it
yourself
and you fall flat in your face
that's where you learn it the most
because the next time when you fall you
learn to catch yourself and that's the
lesson you never forget so everyone was
a wargame and man everyone's to sit back
and what is and before they start their
journey they want to plan it out war
game and war gaming just get going man
get going you're learning along the way
and some of you won't be a fitness model
so try to figure out all pictus miles
stuff to be a fitness model but you just
fall in love with passion I know a lot
of people that started out to be a
fitness model but that wasn't a real
passion but they didn't know until I
started it and now that I like the
photographer or the editor or an actor
coming up to LA that now is a great
producer or director you don't know what
the field is just get going and figure
it out you know and then the truth will
surface you know action causes reaction
you know if you stand still and it's
edited States you know if you're a pond
you know in sedative what grows in
there's algae mosquitoes no one wants
that but you have a current you know a
palette or something it's like in a way
since people want to come and look at it
your life has to be moving the same way
when you guys are sitting on the couch
wherever you are watching this to take
that first step towards greatness it's
very hard that's the hardest step of
everything is that first step right yeah
at first step towards greatness is hard
what's a lot harder it's when time
expires in life you look back on your
life knowing you could have been great
that's something you can't control
anymore cuz times run out I had the
greatest job in the world it's a job
where I get to put out what I do what I
love to do and help to inspire people to
do what they love and achieve things I
come these Expos and people wait three
hours or even more drive 10 hours or a
plane and they wait in these lines and
to come to me and they say thank you for
everything you're doing you've really
saved my life for your huge motivation a
huge difference and they don't
understand how much that means to me
because that's the greatest thing in
life that's the legacy that you actually
do something to leave an impact towards
others and there's no greater honor than
that it's not until I come here and
someone takes time out of their day that
gives value to what I do you know they
use it to transform themselves to give
belief in themselves to change the light
to become the person you've always
wanted to be and they come they share
that and they thank me for that but the
thing is it's their sweat on their shirt
not mine I just help them believe in
themselves and to have a small impact in
a better betterment of their life
and just humbles me so much and so
that's why I think are the greatest job
in the world because uh the return on
investment it's not a monetary value
what's the value that that builds legacy
not the dog in the fight that matters
it's the fighting a dog that matters
same with you it's not your genetics or
your potential its how bad you want it
going to the gym it's not about like
checking the boss did you know paid my
dues today I go in there and I find it a
it's self discovery you know it's like
there's something about that a threat
when you can't do it you know of who you
are when you're pushing it trying to get
it up and do we just quit we just rack
it work we racket drop the weight and
keep going for the burn or do we get
someone to spot us who are we in that
adversity do we push past it do we try
to get more out of it or do we settle do
we say words like good enough and if you
do say good enough you're in trouble
because you don't know if you have
enough until later so I would say if you
never use terms like good enough
tomorrow you always have enough so I can
leave it all there when I work out and
that way no matter what happens later in
life I knows you know not because my
shortcomings done today you know those
three reps that could have done is that
the difference of me being successful
later I don't know that's why I do those
three reps I never have to wonder what
it how to restate motor via guys one get
a partner champions come in pairs of two
because they bow themselves in
perfection a partner is not only an
asset to you on the physical side but
also the mental side meaning when you
guys are coming home from work or
something or maybe the wife is just
yelling at you too much and that's
kidding driving you into a migraine
where the kids you know it's one of
those days you know the bosses on your
he's like I just need to go to the bar
or something you know well if you have a
partner your partner some corner amen
buddy Jim you like do man has had a long
day and everything else and it's not
feeling man like on the gym you know and
so you let him down
now we can all fool ourselves and barely
the real truth inside of us of why we're
not going
right and kid ourselves for whatever
reasons are these excuses I mean nothing
but give them value give them weight to
make us not go so we can fail on our own
account but you gotta be a really low to
fail on some way that's relying on you
very few people do that when you make a
commitment a verbal written commit to
somebody you're me and your word means
you mean something to them when they
call you up to hey let's go and you like
to mail not into it man I into it Wow so
you're not into it not only affects you
but also affects someone else's state
know what's going to happen that guy's
gonna pull you into the gym
drag your through the workout even
though you were all you didn't want to
and by expending that energy at tired
state you're gonna come at it doing
since a priori leaf well you know more
found energy like wow man I know that
felt good now you move back into your
problems that you didn't want to do the
jinkers are overwhelming and you can
look at them differently now I'm sorry
you can see the problems we're solutions
because your your mind you're thinking
smarter you're thinking more more about
the glass headphones at an empty you
know and you know I find remedies and
solutions those problems makes for a
better day combine that for all of them
good week good month good year also
partners really key because you're going
to have hit you're going to tell you
right the partners we have use for
scraps three four reps those are in
pushing past failure we're gonna feel
that hi Wow then you feel that pump
you're gonna feel alive on top of that
you guys are going to go through the
same workout routines right now person a
I say Joe is I'm going to person be John
and say man now that way feelin John you
feeling it and John would be like yeah
man I'm totally feeling it and joe cagg
well well John you know what I'm doing
wrong yeah I think you're doing this way
let me try that oh you and I feel it so
you guys can get in push and pull off
each other on what is working what isn't
working so you find a mental strength or
you like hey man Johnny Ola I'm really
feeling this but you know what I'm not
seeing the results as much um you know
what's your diet like what are you doing
well I'm doing this and doing that and
you guys start comparing each other you
know and you guys are feeding off what
is working what isn't working cuz you
guys are team partners are essential
guys if you don't a partner you really
can't push yourself past the current
limitations and so it's force reps and
failures and drop sets and everything
else to really get the most bang for the
buck okay partner must get a partner
thank you guys for watching I made this
video because
Alliance asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
leave
in the comments below and I'll see what
I can do for you hi I hae them
thank you for watching continue to
believe and I'll see you soon